était vraiment marilyn monroe voici
maintenant une exclusivité france de 48
ans après sa mort loin de l'icône
glamour superficiel on apprend que la
blonde platine la plus célèbre du monde
était en réalité amateurs de littérature
et de poésie
voici en avant première ses carnets
intimes à paraître la semaine prochaine
bruno le dreff jean jacques le garrec en
noir et blanc ou en couleur
assise debout en voiture ou en avion
on ne voyait qu'elle mais qu'en disait
dont on vantait ses formes on moquait
son cerveau elle n'était pourtant pas si
simple marilyn monroe
elle visait mieux elle écrivait sur des
feuilles volantes ou deux petits carnets
comme celui ci les voici montré pour la
première fois depuis sa mort en août 62
il était conservé à new york
elle commence à écrire à 17 ans raconte
son premier mariage pas très heureux son
mari la trompe et ses débuts difficiles
d'actrice
j'étais une fille mince et joliment
faite à 15 ans j'avais joué le rôle
principal dans une pièce pour la télé
c'est un éditeur français qui a obtenu
au hasard d'un dîner de publier ses
écrits inconnu quelques uns venus
s'asseoir à côté de moi m'a dit voilà
j'ai repris un peu on a les affaires de
la succession marilyn monroe
depuis quelques mois on a trouvé des
papiers on aimerait avoir la vie d'un
éditeur marilyn monroe écrivait la
plupart du temps au crayon à papier des
textes courts poèmes écrits intimes
comme j'aimerais être morte
absolument non existantes parti loin
d'ici peu et parfois même une recette de
cuisine
pas de révélations sur ses amours ses
relations avec la famille kennedy sa
carrière mais c'est bien une autre femme
que l'on découvre
les études une fille qui s'est fait
confiance dans un système et que tu
utilisais comme une poupée sexy
charnellement pulpeuse en fait sont
révèle être quelqu'un elle voulait
habite à new york avril trois
intellectuels marilyn monroe un mythe
dont on découvre avec ses écrits une
nouvelle phase